you walked in with a gift and very few
people do that yeah this is very nice
for you brought me a book
by the great werner herzog
which i i don't have this book is this
fairly new it's no it's no book is it a
novel or is it his uh it's a novel this
is great can i read the inscription or
is this private sure you can read it
conan today you are fitzgeraldo
and it's up to you to get me up and over
that mountain in the peruvian jungle and
let's face it it might not be worth it
when we get there your friend luke
i love this have you encountered uh
werner herzog no i've no i haven't but
yeah i've been i've read a couple of uh
reviews of the book it's about a guy
that was on a it's a japanese guy that
after the war ended he stayed on this
island yes famously yeah yeah he didn't
know the war was over
and he stayed right until the 70s and
then in the 1970s some tourists were on
the island and they were getting shot at
they're like what's going on
and uh he wouldn't come out
i know the real story i don't know uh
werner herzog's version i just know the
real story which is they had to go to
japan and get his now very old commander
to come back and tell him you're
relieved of duty
yeah i mean uh because he
wouldn't accept that the war was over
and he had to hear it from his commander
who was
you know working at a rite aid in tokyo
so i mean
that's how it'll eventually end for us
here in hollywood
your first agent will show up
no you're just firing jokes out of a
cave yeah firing jokes out of a musket
conan conan come out it's fine it's over
there is no show at radio city
the preparations for nothing so nice but
you're a big reader i know you're a big
reader because you're always talking to
me about books you've just been reading
or read i buy a lot of books you know i
recently got that from you build shelves
with them
you use them to prop up things
i always i'm always looking for a good
book tend to read a lot of you know
biographies and read a lot about music
and stuff like that it's not as if i'm
reading kind of
deep uh you know intellectual texts well
it's funny i have a thing uh my wife
pretty much only reads fiction and she
that's good she reads the classics and
she's very uh incredibly smart and
um and and literate and i
always my go-to
was
history i will only read history and my
attitude was i just want to know what
i've got to know what happened i need to
know what happened i don't have time to
waste on someone's made up story
you know and she'll say like
and and she'll say you know i'm you know
i'm reading like this classic of
literature you know and uh you know i'm
i'm reading dostoyevsky or something i'm
like that's all made up
withering and blathering
i've got to know what really happened so
that's my go-to
i'm trying to get out of that i'm trying
to read more and more fiction yeah i try
and read a little fiction here and there
it is great when you do find a good
fiction book but i i will say that i had
somehow had read an elmore leonard
book and all i'd really known was kind
of get shorty you know just that was
kind of the first thing i knew but gosh
he really has incredible i mean it kind
of got me into reading crime and guys
like ross mcdonald but elmore leonard's
books are really
just so fun to read yeah if you don't if
you're not big into fiction i mean
they're they're really kind of fun
really funny too good good stuff with
like you know friends and cops and
criminals and really really good sharp
dialogue i started reading kurt vonnegut
again recently i don't know why i just
was like oh it's so funny it's dark
that's cool and sad
but it's it's as sharp today as it was i
mean it's unbelievable that he wrote it
you know 40 50 years ago and it's just
still that funny and kind of applies to
today and so yeah i've never read any of
his stuff kind of read more about him as
a person well you're going to go home
okay
there's slaughterhouse five and
breakfast of champions and then we'll
talk okay that's what summer reading
that's what this podcast has turned into
just me bullying people
into reading books that i just picked up
and maybe won't finish
oh come on you gotta feed these finish
these these are amazing they're
incredible